By now, we have defined the
notion of independence of
events and also the notion of
independence of random variables.
The two definitions look
fairly similar, but the
details are not exactly the
same, because the two
definitions refer to different
situations.
For two events, we know what
it means for them to be
independent.
The probability of their
intersection is the product of
their individual
probabilities.
Now, to make a relation with
random variables, we introduce
the so-called indicator
random variables.
So for example, the random
variable X is defined to be
equal to 1 if event A occurs
and to be equal
to 0 if event [A]
does not occur.
And there is a similar
definition for random variable
Y.
In particular, the probability
that random variable X takes
the value of 1, this
is the probability
that event A occurs.
It turns out that the
independence of the two
events, A and B, is equivalent
to the independence of the two
indicator random variables.
And there is a similar
statement, which
is true more generally.
That is, n events are
independent if and only if the
associated n indicator random
variables are independent.
This is a useful statement,
because it allows us to
sometimes, instead of
manipulating events, to
manipulate random variables,
and vice versa.
And depending on the
context, one maybe
easier than the other.
Now, the intuitive content is
that events A and B are
independent if the occurrence
of event A does not change
your beliefs about B. And in
terms of random variables, one
random variable taking a certain
value, which indicates
whether event A has occurred or
not does not give you any
information about the other
random variable, which would
tell you whether event B
has occurred or not.
It is instructive now to go
through the derivation of this
fact, at least for the case of
two events, because it gives
us perhaps some additional
understanding about the
precise content of the
definitions we have
introduced.
So let us suppose that random
variables X and Y are
independent.
What does that mean?
Independence means that the
joint PMF of the two random
variables, X and Y, factors as a
product of the corresponding
marginal PMFs.
And this factorization must be
true no matter what arguments
we use inside the joint PMF.
And the combination of X and Y
in this instance have a total
of four possible values.
These are the combinations
of zeroes and
ones that we can form.
And for this reason, we have
a total of four equations.
These four equalities are what
is required for X and Y to be
independent.
So suppose that this is true,
that the random variables are
independent.
Let us take this first relation
and write it in
probability notation.
The random variable X taking
the value of 1, that's the
same as event A occurring.
And random variable Y taking
the value of 1, that's the
same as event B occurring.
So the joint PMF evaluated at
1, 1 is the probability that
events A and B both occur.
On the other side of the
equation, we have the
probability that X is equal to
1, which is the probability
that A occurs, and similarly,
the probability that B occurs.
But if this is true, then by
definition, A and B are
independent events.
So we have verified one
direction of this statement.
If the random variables are
independent, then events A and
B are independent.
Now, we would like to verify
the reverse statement.
So suppose that events A
and B are independent.
In that case, this
relation is true.
And as we just argued, this
relation is the same as this
relation but just written
in different notation.
So we have shown that if A and
B are independent, this
relation will be true.
But how about the remaining
three relations?
We have more work to do.
Here's how we can proceed.
If A and B are independent, we
have shown some time ago that
events A and B complement will
also be independent.
Intuitively, A doesn't tell
you anything about
B occuring or not.
So A does not tell you anything
about whether B
complement will occur or not.
Now, these two events being
independent, by the definition
of independence, we have that
the probability of A
intersection with B complement
is the product of the
probabilities of A and
of B complement.
And then we realize that this
equality, if written in PMF
notation, corresponds exactly
to this equation here.
Event A corresponds to X taking
the value of 1, event B
complement corresponds to
the event that Y takes
the value of 0.
By a similar argument, B and
A complement will be
independent.
And we translate that into
probability notation.
And then we translate this
equality into PMF notation.
And we get this relation.
Finally, using the same property
that we used to do
the first step here, we have
that A complement and B
complement are also
independent.
And by following the same line
of reasoning, this implies the
fourth relation as well.
So we have verified that
if events A and B are
independent, then we can argue
that all of these four
equations will be true.
And therefore, random variables
X and Y will also be
independent.